Hey look guys my name is the Chano and
welcome back to my paper floss series
today I'm going to be talking all about
pluses in tip or flood so finally
getting is something called
object-oriented programming which is a
very popular way of programming
object-oriented programming is really
just a style that you can adult as to
how you write your code other languages
such as spaceship and Java are primarily
object artists languages in fact you
can't really write any other type of
code I mean you can if you really really
try but ultimately those languages are
meant to be of your hunted languages
however say for plus is something a
little bit different because it doesn't
really import a certain style upon you
the language speed for example doesn't
actually support of your drawing
programming because in order to have
object-oriented programming you need to
be able to have concepts such as classes
and object and that's not something
that's available and see however pepper
sauce does add all of that functionality
if you wish to use it and it is almost
always a good idea to use it to some
extent so we're gonna be talking about
what classes are in this video to put it
simply classes are just a way to group
data and/or functionality
together for example think of a game in
a game we might want to have some kind
of representation as a player so what
kind of things do we need to actually
represent a player we definitely want
some kind of data for example the
position of the player in our game while
certain attributes of the player might
possess such as the speed at which the
player moves we might also want to have
some kind of 3d model that represents
the player on the screen all of this
data needs to be stored somewhere we
could go ahead and create variables for
all this in fact let's go ahead and take
a look at what that would look like
let's say that we want to make a player
here in our code we might want to have a
position so I'll just say X&Y and then
potentially a speed let's just have a
speed equal to 2 so these are all
integers for now you can probably start
to see that this is getting a little bit
messy and in fact because these names
are so generic you might want to do
something like player acts player Y for
the X and y coordinate of the player
maybe play a speed and this really does
start to get a little bit messy
especially if we decide actually we want
to players in our game well then
suddenly you're going to have to
duplicate this and start doing something
like plaque there a player x1 instead of
this you could of course use an array
but the point is still the same it's
just kind of a bunch of variables that
aren't group together they're just
unorganized they're just sitting in our
code and it's not a good idea another
great example of why this is annoying is
because if I want to write a function
that moves the player or something like
that I suddenly need to be specifying
all three parameters as integers so for
example the x coordinates and Y
coordinates at speed all of this becomes
so much code and Laura difficult to
maintain and follow that it's just it's
really really messy so what we can do
instead is simplify this by using a
class we can create a class for the
player we can call it player which
contains all of that data that we want
all the variables kind of in one time so
instead of this let's create a class
called player we do so by just using the
work class and then giving it a name
this has to be a unique name because
classes are types we're basically
creating a new variable type and then we
open in close curly brackets as if this
was a function however notice that we do
actually need a semicolon at the end of
the closing brace inside here we can
specify all of those variables that we
did below for example X and Y for the
position and then a be variable as well
all right great there we go we've
created a brand new class called player
which is essentially its own type so if
we were to start using this player class
we can create it as if it was any other
variable we write the type so player and
then we give it any name I'm going to
call this player and that's it we've
created a new variable called player
which has the type player and of course
the definition of that type is over here
variables that are made from class types
are called objects and a new object
variable is called an instance so what
we've done here is we've instantiated a
player object because we've credit a new
instance of that player type now if we
want to set those variables we can
simply write player dot and then the
variable names such as X and then assign
it equal to something like 5 if we try
and compile the code right now we're
actually going to get an error that
tells us that player cannot access
private member declared in class player
this is because of something called
visibility when you create a new class
you have the option to specify how
visible the
in that cloth actually is by default a
cloth makes everything private which
means that only functions inside that
cloth can actually access those
variables however we want to be able to
access these variables from the main
function so what we actually need to do
is come up here and make it public
public means that we're allowed to
access these variables outside of this
class anywhere in our code really we'll
talk a lot more about visibility in a
future video I don't really want to get
into it right now so you can see if we
compile our code here then outside
compiled successfully okay pretty sweet
so we've achieved our first goal we've
managed to drastically clean up the code
and have all of our variables in one
place because really this collection of
variables represent the player so we've
managed to croak it nicely now that
we've got all this data
suppose that we actually want our player
to do something for example move
somewhere so we need to write a function
which changes the player's x and y
variables how can we do that well we
could write it as just a standalone
function
so I'll write void I'll call it moved
and then I would need to take in the
player that I would like to move and I
will have to pass by reference because
will actually be modifying the player of
U and then I'll also take in X a and Y a
which will be the amount that we move
the player by in both x and y then all I
need to do is just say player 2 X plus B
equals X a and player 2 y + equals y a
we can also use that speed variable that
we have there by multiplying our amount
by B speed all right pretty cool and if
we wanted to call that we would just
write move player and then Y how much we
want to move to player so maybe 1 minus
1 and there we go we've written a
function that can move the player
however we can do a little bit that in
this earlier I said that classes can
actually contain functionality so what
that basically means is that we can move
that move function of ours into the
class and functions inside classes are
called methods so I can literally go
over here into my code and just move
this a little bit up so that it's inside
the player class and there we go now
obviously we're inside the player class
now so we actually have access to these
variables we don't need to pass a player
object in because we're already inside a
player object so if I get rid of this
and then all of these the x and y and
speed that we're referring to will be
the current object variable if I come
down over here I can change my code now
to just say player don't move
and there we go we've simplified our
quote quite a bit every player object is
going to have its own move function and
when we call move for that specific
player object that is the player object
that will move again this isn't really
any different to having the move
function outside of the player class all
it does is it kind of cleans up our code
and makes everything look a little bit
nicer and that's a huge bonus when
you're dealing with a lot of code
because the more code you have the more
complicated it can get and the harder it
can actually become to maintain that
code so having games like this to keep
the code cleaner is actually a very very
welcome thing so that's it that is
essentially the basics of what classes
are classes allow us to group variables
together into a type and also add
functionality to those variables because
if you take a look at this code one more
time what we've really done is we've
just defined three variables the kind of
exist in one type and also a function
which manipulates
those variables that's really all we've
done of course that function can do
literally anything but the gist of it is
we've got data and functions to
manipulate that data and that's really
all the classes now there are so many
uses for classes and we'll kind of start
getting into them in the future
this is also literally just the basics
of what a class is there are so many
more things we can do with classes which
is why the next few videos are going to
be taking a look at those things in more
detail also I want you to keep in mind
that whilst classes are extremely useful
and can keep your code a lot cleaner
they can't do anything that you can't do
without classes buttons don't give you
any kind of new functionality that you
could not have done otherwise anything
you can do with classes you can actually
do without classes which is why
languages such as C is this and I've
perfectly usable languages they don't
have classes and yet we can still write
code classes are just there to make our
life easier a programmer they're
essentially just syntactic sugar that we
can use to organize our code and make it
easier to maintain that's all they are
anyway I hope you guys enjoy this video
if you did please hit that like button
you can also follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and of course next time we'll
be taking a look at this stuff in more
detail and seeing just what we can do
with it goodbye
[Music]
[Music]